nach ersten erkenntnissen begaben sich
die beiden bewaffneten täter gegen 15.50
in das juweliergeschäft in der neuen
straße niedersächsischen celle offenbar
mit dem ziel dieses zu überfallen
während der tat kam es dann zur abgabe
mehrere schüsse in den geschäftsräumen
die polizei celle hat die ermittlungen
aufgenommen um die näheren tatumstände
sowie die identität der räuber
aufzuklären dort befinden sich zur zeit
des überfalls nur die täter und das
inhaberehepaar 71 und 72 jahre alt
nähere einzelheiten werden aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen aktuell
nicht bekannt gegeben der betreiber
steht natürlich unter schock
es ist auch für ihn keine alltägliche
situation die täter die mutmaßlich den
juwelier überfallen wollten scheinen
nach ersten erkenntnissen bewaffnet
gewesen zu sein weshalb der betreiber
ebenfalls zur waffe gegriffen hat wer
von diesen ganzen vorfall etwas
mitbekommen hat ist hier derzeit nicht
bekannt zeugen werden gebeten sich bei
der polizei in celle zu melden
ja das finde ich sehr schade und
hilliger tage und so was gerade in
witten innenstadt so was passiert das
finde ich nicht normal
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren